The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So I want to
do two things today.
One is wrap up what I
was doing last time.
And the rest of the time, or a
part of the rest of the time,
I want to spend kind of going
back to the questions of what
have we learned, or what do
we think we have learned?
So this is mostly
continuation.
So let me just remind you
what I'm continuing.
The basic point I was trying
to make last time is that
there are always many things
you can do to make even bad
systems allow for relatively
wide range of possible
interventions.
And in reverse, even in good
systems, if you have bad
interventions, they're bad.
The fact that the system is good
has no guarantee that the
interventions that get
chosen are bad.
If you like, in that sequence of
arguments, this is the last
one, which is can you actually
turn bad politics--
is it really prior to policy?
So does it exist outside
politics?
And we sort of made the case
that that's not entirely true
already because we've been
saying things like if people
have some idea of who they
should vote for then they vote
more discriminatively.
Part of the reason why they
don't necessarily use a lot of
discrimination is because
they're not necessarily that
interested in the election.
And that's partly because they
don't have much information.
Here's a nice experiment which
sort of emphasizes that point
on how policies can
mold politics.
This has to do with attitudes
toward women leaders in India.
In India there's a rule which
says that panchayats are the
lowest level of government in
India, these are village
governments essentially.
And India has a rule which says
that 1/3 of all seats of
leader of panchayat, the role of
the boss of the panchayat,
have to be filled by women.
And it turns out that partly
for political reasons they
decided that which of them will
be reserved for women
will be decided by a lottery.
So there was a lottery to decide
out of the 3,000 or how
many thousand villages in this
particular state, how many of
them will have a woman
lead at this time.
And then in principle the
idea is that next time
there will a rotation.
And so the places that are
reserved this time will not be
reserved the next time
and vice versa.
And that didn't actually
happen entirely.
And I'll tell you something
about that in a minute.
But right now think of
it as a lottery and
then we see what happens.
So the advantage of it being a
lottery is that the government
in a sense performed an
experiment for us because they
chose these places
by a lottery.
So we kind of know that they're
identical to start with.
So there was a bunch of
places which had to
have a woman leader.
These places were not a
priori any different
from any other places.
They ended up with
a woman leader.
Now, in terms of outcomes,
there's data that therefore
allows you to compare the
villages that had a woman
leader with places
that didn't.
And there's an outcome that
seems clear that woman leaders
are not obviously worse
than men leaders.
They seem to spend about the
same amount of money.
And when you ask villagers their
view of corruption in
government, they're less likely
to say the government
is corrupt.
So overall if you look at just
the numbers, women seem to be
just as effective as men.
Now, this is not obvious.
Indeed, it's quite surprising
because the women are actually
less experienced.
Often this is the first time
they've had a political job.
Many of them, this is not just
the first time they've had a
political job.
This is the first time they've
ever had a job.
They're less educated than the
men, and they're less likely
to have had run a business
than the men.
That's not surprising.
But given all that, that's often
all of those things that
often are seen as
being attributes
of successful leaders.
It's not surprising maybe that
people still sort of feel that
they should not be able to lead
because people only have
a theory, which is often kind
of a common theory, which is
that if you have been a business
leader or you've had
a business you might be better
at running government.
And so this is a theory you
encounter in the press here
all the time.
So maybe people might very
well believe that.
So the question that's being
asked in this experiment--
so the first round of kind of
this lottery, people observed
what happened.
And, as I said, the answer was
that the women did no worse
than the men.
However, there were still some
hitches in the system.
So on the next round what was
supposed to have happened was
that now there would
be no lottery.
People would just reverse.
And so let's say you had a woman
leader before, now you
wouldn't have one
and vice versa.
That was what supposed
to happen.
In fact, that didn't happen.
What happened was that there
was some political
negotiation.
And they had a second lottery.
So there were places that were
randomly chosen again.
And because there was a second
lottery, some places had women
leaders twice just because they
happened to kind of win
the lottery twice.
Some of them had a lose,
depending on
your point of view.
Some of them had women
leaders once.
And some of them
had zero times.
So this data is after
10 years.
So the data we're going to look
at is at least after more
than five years.
So these are places which
have had a women
leader for several years.
So they've had her first for
five years and then possibly
for another couple of years.
Or they've had men leaders.
So this is sort of data after a
fairly long period of time.
And, as I said, there are three
different groups here.
There are people who've had
women leaders for two terms or
at least one and one plus term,
people who have had
women leaders for one term, and
people who have had women
leaders for zero terms.
So that's the comparison we're
going to be interested in.
So the way the comparison will
be done is interesting.
So they took a real speech that
was given by a leader, a
man leader in this case.
And then they had a woman sort
of speak out the same speech.
So they had two recordings of
the same speech, identical
speech, one in a woman's voice
and one in a man's voice.
And then what they did was they
took these two speeches
to the villagers and asked them
to, you know, and took,
like, a random sample of
villagers and asked them to
say which of the speeches they
thought reflected leader's
competence.
They were hearing a man
speak, a woman speak.
They were hearing exactly
the same speech.
And you're asking them which
one sounds more competent.
So some people were asked about
men, others were asked
about women.
And the idea was precisely to
see if it is the case that the
same speech gets graded
differently, so if people are
bringing something to
the speech which
is not in the speech.
The speech is just a voice
saying the same words.
Are you bringing something
different to it?
You're bringing some
prejudice to it?
You think that women are better,
women are worse,
whatever it is.
This is an attempt to
measure prejudice.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I have a
quick question.
If a woman's a leader do people
in the community think
she does whatever her husband
tells her to do?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
For example, that's an
interesting question.
So when this was implemented,
people basically said this is
not going to change anything.
Women leaders are going to
be just like men leaders.
Why?
Because men will lead
in any case.
The women just will
be decorative.
They'll be on the ballot but
not actually leading.
And indeed in many villages
there is somebody who people
talk about quite casually as
the husband of the leader.
They have a word for it in
Hindi, which is the husband of
the leader.
And that's kind of like First
Lad or something.
So people thought this
will have no effect.
In fact, when you look at the
data, it's clear that places
that were randomly assigned a
woman leader are much more
likely to have investments in
things women care about.
So women mostly care
about water.
And places where women
are leader have more
investment in water.
Water's a big woman issue
because women have to find
drinking water.
Let's say drinking water
is a huge woman issue.
And so when you look at the
village meetings, women ask
questions about water,
drinking water.
And then you look at what
happens if a woman is the head
of the village, you see exactly
that, which is you see
women leaders generate more.
So going back to this
experiment, they were
basically asked to
grade the speech.
And the speech was, as
I said, identical.
So if you thought the man was
more competent, the woman was
more competent, you're bringing
some data to it that
was not in the speech itself.
The speech was word for
word identical.
So this is the comparison
mostly of never reserved
versus twice reserved.
OK, that's the simplest
comparison, one that had a
woman leader twice with
one where it's
never had a woman leader.
The first set of columns, set of
bars, I guess, are for men.
The second set of bars
are for women.
So when it says reserved, male,
that means a man in the
village that has been
reserved twice.
What does the man say?
And the difference is woman's
speech versus
man speech, the rating.
And the result is
quite dramatic.
Men, in general, if you're
never reserved, think the
woman's speech is much worse.
That's the blue bar.
It's negative.
Nonetheless, if you see what
happens after it's reserved
twice, the men change
their mind.
Now the woman's speech
is better.
For women, the original
prejudice was smaller and the
swing is smaller.
That's not maybe surprising
because women start with less
prejudice and then they don't
react as much as well.
On the other hand, they also
ask a different question.
This was kind of a measure
of competence, right?
This was actually asking
them does the
person sound competent?
If you'd actually asked them the
question should a woman be
a leader, they still say no.
So it's not that they
changed their mind.
It's that objective judgment
has changed.
They feel less negative
about women.
The test is still
against women.
But somehow once you've been
exposed to women leaders, you
realize that they're just
as good as men.
You might feel that they're
really not a good idea.
Women should not
be in this job.
But when you look at who does
the job, you figure that
they're just as good
as others.
There's a similar experiment
that was done in--
so this is sort of continuing
that same data.
This is actually election
outcome.
So this is comparing how what
fraction of women get elected.
Now, in unreserved seats--
so these were seats in 2008 that
had been reserved once,
twice, or zero times.
That's what you're comparing.
You're taking seats in 2008
that are not reserved.
Now, some of these seats in '98
and 2003 were reserved.
Some were reserved once.
Some were reserved twice.
This is the third election.
So do you understand?
So instead of asking what is
your preferences, this is
asking what did you observe?
How did you vote actually?
Did you support women?
And, here, again you see
the same pattern.
These are two different jobs.
So the greens are
different jobs.
So the Pradhan is
the top leader.
The ward councillor is the
next level leader.
And if you look at both,
you just see that they
just keep going up.
So if you reserve more, you
vote more for women.
These are unreserved seats.
So right now you're not required
to vote for women.
And if you start with the
ones which are never
reserved, you get 9%.
The ones who you reserved twice,
you get twice as much.
So basically people's political
judgments are
substantially shifted by
being reserved twice.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Is there any data on
the quality of leadership
between women who run in the non
reserved village versus in
a reserved village?
PROFESSOR: There's certainly
data on--
I don't know the answer
to that question.
My guess is that if women who
won the unreserved villages
are better.
And that's what you'd expect.
And I remember somebody saying
that they're more educated
definitely.
So if you have the confidence to
run without any reservation
then you are probably better
situated in any case.
And that seems to be true.
I don't remember.
The same data that is used to
say that women leaders are
less corrupt than men leaders
must also say something about
reserved versus unreserved
women.
I just don't know the answer.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Could this just be
because more women are running
in areas [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Oh, absolutely.
But that's an outcome, right?
Women are running.
And so part of it is that
they're more incumbent.
But the fact is that, for
whatever reason, once you
expose people to the possibility
that they can vote
for women, they vote
for women.
So in other words, policies
change politics.
That's the point I wanted to
make, which was sort of
something I've been pushing
for a while, but just to
understand this we
talked about.
And so basically to summarize
it's not that political
constraints are not important.
And lots of political events
have huge consequences.
But that shouldn't stop us.
The main point we're making here
is that that shouldn't
stop us in the fight for looking
for better policies
because, A, better policies are
implementable even when
the politics is often bad.
You often still get some
good policies.
And second, if you have got a
chance to have a good policy,
you better have one ready.
So imagine the politics shifted
and somebody asked
you, this is what
I want to do.
What would you do?
You would do something very,
very, very, different if you
knew or if you thought
about it.
And, moreover, if you do
undertake better policies,
voters react.
So there's no fixed prejudice
that makes voters completely
unresponsive to performance.
If you show performance,
voters seem to react.
And especially if there's
strong evidence that the
policy is working, people
react even more.
So the one story that I think is
on this slide and is worth
mentioning is the story of a
program called Progresa, which
is a Mexican program which has
now been imitated in many,
many countries, including,
briefly, by Mayor Bloomberg in
New York City.
This is a program called a
conditional cash transfer,
basically a program which told
parents that if their children
were immunized and sent to
school, they'll get a little
bit of money or quite a bit
of money, actually.
So they were paying parents to
make sure that the parents
send their children to school.
So when this program was
launched, the person who
launched it realized that in
Mexico every six years the
president changes and all
the policies change.
And so the policy would die in
six years even if it was a
great policy.
So what he did is he actually
got a bunch of people from
University of Pennsylvania,
University of California
involved in evaluating
the program.
And it was introduced in a
random way so you could
compare the places where the
policies was implemented to
the places that were not.
And there was a bunch of well
known scholars from all over
the world who were
evaluating it.
Their results came out
very positive.
So as the guy who had
implemented it expected, the
party that was in power then
lost the elections.
So a new president came in
from a different party.
And he immediately said we have
to shut down Progresa
because Progresa is a previous
government's program.
We don't like it.
So it was shut down.
But immediately he replaced it
with a slightly different
program which was essentially
identical to it called
Oportunidades.
So basically the fact that there
was all this evidence
out there made it very difficult
for them to actually
shut it down.
And so the program actually
survived and now has spread to
many countries.
So the general point to be made
here is that I think it's
too easy to assume that,
well, the political
system is very powerful.
We just cannot change
anything.
And, therefore, we shouldn't
intervene.
But, in fact, when you actually
are strategic about
playing that game, you do
get lots of leverage.
This Progresa example is an
excellent example of how you
need to be strategic about
the user information.
But if you are strategic then
you might be capable of
generating lots of change.
So that's sort of one general
point I wanted to make.
But I have a set of slides
which are an attempt to
summarize all the general points
we wanted to make.
So let me just go
through them.
So what I want to do is
this is the heading.
The end of our book is called
"in place of a sweeping
conclusion." And you can imagine
why we don't want a
sweeping conclusion since our
whole point is that there is
not one conclusion.
There's not one solution
that will solve all the
problems in the world.
There's no sense in claiming
that there is one answer.
However it's sort of useful
to illustrate some general
principles.
And so what I'm going to do is
I'm going to go through a few
of, I think, the five key
principles that we think are
useful to keep in mind whenever
you're thinking about
these issues.
So this is the first one.
So do you remember any
examples of this?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I think it was they
believe, for health and
disease stuff, they believe
that the suggestions the
religious leaders were giving
were better than
the medicines that--
PROFESSOR: For example.
Others?
There were many.
Sorry?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: What about examples
of situations where the poor
seem to act as if they don't
have key pieces of information
or they have beliefs which are
sort of maybe misplaced?
We went over many during
the-- yeah.
AUDIENCE: Education has an
S-shaved curve to it.
PROFESSOR: Right.
That education has very high
returns at the top and almost
no returns at the bottom.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Probably make more
sense to invest in education
for women [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
We talked about, for example,
the belief that you should get
a shot rather than a tablet
whenever you get sick.
Typically a tablet is much safer
than a shot and does
exactly the same thing.
What's another example?
The other examples that we
discussed a lot are examples
not so much of the wrong belief
as much as the lack of
belief, that people often don't
seem to believe that
different technologies are
as effective as we think.
So one of the reasons why people
don't want bed nets is
they don't seem to believe
that bed nets will work.
And when you give people bed
nets and they use them, a year
later they're willing to
buy it at full price.
A lot more of them are willing
to buy it at full price
because they see that they're
useful and usable.
The fact that you go and tell
them this is great for you is
not enough.
They don't believe you.
So when they use it, they
start believing you.
Or another example of rather
weak beliefs is immunization.
People sort of think that
immunization, maybe it works,
maybe it doesn't.
It's not that they don't go to
get immunized, but they don't
really make sure that their
children get all the
immunizations.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Well, fertilizer is
kind of a counter example in
that they know it works, but
then they try [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Absolutely.
So the converse was
not being claimed.
It's not that the poor
only believe
things which are false.
AUDIENCE: That was just a lack
of information [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
You're right.
It's a good example.
But it is something where that's
certainly not what we
were claiming.
The second one is we say that
the poor bear responsibility
for far too much
of their lives.
And what do we mean here?
What are examples?
AUDIENCE: There are examples
in health.
For instance, they have to
decide every time about
purification of water.
And [INAUDIBLE]
many examples.
AUDIENCE: I was going to
mention those, too.
But also maybe education.
You have a system
of [INAUDIBLE]
school systems working well in
poor villages [INAUDIBLE]
no idea that there's children
not learning anything actually
at school [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
That's a nice example.
Water's a very good example.
Typically I think lots of people
have said why don't
poor people use, like,
water purification?
And it's true that they
should use it.
But think of what it means.
It means every time you use
water, you have to make sure
it's purified.
Whereas for us, we just don't
even worry about it.
We run the tap.
So in some sense we
have it so easy.
So think about pensions.
If you work at MIT, somebody
deducts pension money from
your salary, puts it into an
account, and somebody else
invests it for you.
And you have no choice
over it.
But on the other hand, you know
that something's being
done about it.
If you're poor, you have to
invest the money all by
yourself and make sure that,
you know, it's getting the
right returns or finding
a place that's safe.
We don't solve any of
those problems.
Education's a great
one actually.
I think we can take
as given that the
school systems are rated.
We have the ability to
evaluate what our
children are learning.
If you're poor then you
really don't know.
If you want to actually make
sure your child is learning,
you have to go and find somebody
else who does know
how to read and write and get
him to intervene and make sure
that the child is learning.
Do you want--
yeah?
AUDIENCE: I don't know if this
falls under what [INAUDIBLE].
It probably does.
But insurance because I think
bearing responsibility for
major things that are external
to their future [INAUDIBLE],
whereas if you bring
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right.
So that's absolutely right.
In the US, if there's a big
storm then FEMA steps in.
And sometimes it doesn't work
so well like in New Orleans.
But it's on average that there's
a huge number of
federal agencies that are there
to guarantee you some
minimum living and to help you
rebuild your houses and all
that disaster relief.
If the same storm happens in
some less well run country
then in some sense
you know that is
going to be your problem.
So you spend all your time
worrying about what will you
have to do about it.
In the US, you basically know
that if it's something that's
really out of control then it
will be taken care of mostly.
And that's even more true
in other countries.
Among rich countries, the US is
particularly laissez faire.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] you're
saying [INAUDIBLE]
poor people than
poor countries.
Because I think that a lot of
this stuff, this also does
apply [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Absolutely.
So I think poor people in rich
countries have many of the
same issues.
For example, if you don't have
a regular job, you don't get
health insurance.
You don't get pensions.
So you have to then decide to
do your savings on your own.
You have to find a way to fund
your health problems on your
own, et cetera.
You bear much more response--
for an MIT professor, so many
things are taken care of, which
if you were poor, they
wouldn't be.
So that's absolutely right.
This is also true, as Melissa
said, of poor people all over
the world, including the US.
Markets will work less
well for poor people.
And the corollary of that is
therefore you should not
always pin your fate on
markets delivering.
So what's an example of markets
working less well for
people and why would they
work less well?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: The insurance market,
performing [INAUDIBLE]
just because the information
[INAUDIBLE]
to form institutions in some of,
I guess, the [INAUDIBLE].
So that's why they form more
informal insurance markets
where family members and
community members try to
insure against a bad shock.
PROFESSOR: Right.
That's a great example.
You don't really have access
to formal insurance because
maybe you are just not valuable
enough and you're too
far away from the insurance
company.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I guess the mosquito
net market because they don't
see the importance
or the value of
buying a mosquito net.
So you have to give it away
first to convince them of its
importance.
But you also have to make sure
to give it away [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: They don't mostly.
I think we talked about the
evidence [INAUDIBLE].
Yep.
AUDIENCE: There's talk about the
fertilizer market and how
people might have had money
at the right time when
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: If you have
no place to sort of--
one thing that makes life very
difficult for people in
agriculture it that they
get their entire
salary all at once.
And then they have to figure out
a way to spend it smoothly
over a period of time because
they're going to get no money
for a long time.
We get paid every week
or every month.
So even if you spent the last
month's income, we have this
month's income coming in.
If you have an income every six
months, you have to have
that much more self restraint.
And so poor people are often
farmers, and they have to deal
with these very large ups and
downs in incomes which we
don't have a deal with at all.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Maybe of giving
things away.
You have to give away
a bag of rice to get
people to get vaccines.
So it's more about
the [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Exactly.
Once the market doesn't
work then you have to
think of what to do.
We talked about the credit
market where in the credit
market the reason why the poor
end up paying much higher
interest rates is because
there's this vicious circle of
if you are poor then nobody's
going to lend
you a lot of money.
So since you're going to be lent
a very small amount of
money then the interest rate
will have to cover the cost of
enforcing the loan.
And that's kind of
a fixed cost.
So if that's, let's say, $10
and you are borrowing $10
million, then that's nothing.
If you were borrowing $10, then
that's, you know, 100%.
So you get a much bigger
kick from having
high interest rates.
And then it turns into this kind
of further vicious cycle
because if the interest rate is
high then the incentive to
default is higher and then you
have to spend even more money
making sure that people
don't default.
But that then raises the
interest rate even more.
So you get this vicious cycle of
you start by being poor and
you end up with a very
high interest rate.
That's one of the reasons why
the poor find it very
difficult to borrow.
So this one we talked
about already.
This is the one we were
talking about a lot.
So I'll skip it and go to the
last one, which is that a lot
of what keeps people in
poverty is just the
expectations of hopelessness
and
expectations of negative outcomes.
Do you want to give
examples of that?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
give them a test and then told
them to stay for the test or
not, like, making them
aware [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Louder.
AUDIENCE: Basically, in
education, students
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right.
So students are often told that
because they didn't do
well in their first grade test
that they're stupid.
And if they believe they're
stupid, they stop trying.
What's another example?
AUDIENCE: That, like, we saw
that if the poor believe that
they are not going to earn
much from a particular
profession then they will not
pursue that [INAUDIBLE]
business.
PROFESSOR: Right.
So if you think that the rewards
that you're going to
get from some investment are
pretty small so your life
won't really change in any
substantial way then you might
just give up and not try very
much to do anything
innovative.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: There's also the
savings example of always
expecting [INAUDIBLE]
about that can be suspended as
who's qualified [INAUDIBLE].
Knowing that some things can
come up that's going to
require money gives an incentive
to try to save.
PROFESSOR: Right.
So you might expect that
somebody will tax it away
somehow and then you'll
never want to save.
Any other examples?
So I just wanted to then wrap
up in a couple of minutes.
Let me say a couple of things.
I'm going to wrap up in
a couple of minutes.
One thing is that you should
really give us the evaluation
for this class.
It's the first time we taught it
in this format, and I have
no idea what the specific
problems are and
what we could do better.
So it will be helpful for us.
And it's only fair to the two
TAs who work very hard on this
to get feedback on what they've
done because that
actually matters for, for
example, when they go in the
job market.
This is something
that matters.
I know it's something
easy to forget.
But you should remember
to do it.
Other than that, I guess, just
to wrap up, this was an
attempt to kind of expose
you to how people--
I think mostly people from
sort of the community of
people associated with the
Poverty Action Lab but also, I
think, development, economics
more generally think about
issues around poverty.
And I think the thing that I
think you should take away
from this is not that we have
solved the problem of poverty.
I think that would be an
overstatement by some margin.
But at least that at this point
that there's a huge gap
between the way, kind of, the
journalistic accounts of
poverty operate, the level at
which they operate and the
level at which all of us now
after this conversation should
approach it.
In some ways there is a very
large and relatively stable
body of knowledge about what
the big issues are and what
the sticking points are.
There's a sense in
which we are--
I don't know that we have
all the answers or
even all the problems.
But at least some problems have
been clearly identified.
They keep coming back,
the same problems.
And we kind of know how to think
about them, what can we
do about it.
In that sense there is a sense
in which I think there's
reason to be optimistic.
If you think about something I
keep saying, is that if you
think about sort of social
policy and policy against
poverty, the first thing to
remember is that this is an
extraordinarily modern
invention, that basically
other than supporting the
extremely destitute at some
very low level there was no
government policy to help the
poor at all really ever.
If you were extremely poor,
somebody would feed you.
But mostly there was
nothing else.
I mean the education systems
really didn't exist except for
the elites.
Health systems didn't exist
except in the private market.
And other forms of insurance
didn't exist.
If you look at the world in
1900, the most striking fact
about it is how small
governments are.
No government is spending
more than 10% of GDP.
Tax collections are maximum
10% of GDP.
Now, if you take, like, Sweden,
tax collections are
55% of GDP--
so just to think of the range.
So what has happened over the
last 100 years, and actually
not even 100 years, really after
the First World War, was
a massive expansion of things
that governments do.
And more generally a massive
expansion of systematic
interventions to help people
live their lives better.
Education systems massively
expanded.
Health care massively
Social support programs
massively expanded.
In general the world of sort
of interventions is a very
modern world.
This whole idea that there
should be social policy to
help the poor and all of us
should worry about it is a
very, very recent idea.
So the fact that we haven't
got it right
already is no surprise.
In some sense, what happened was
even between 1920 or 1910
and 1950, there's a massive
expansion of governments in
rich countries.
Then a bunch of poor countries
became independent and they
imitated the rich countries by
also substantially expanding
their government.
And then they often didn't have
the experience, the state
capacity, the bureaucratic
capacity to
implement those programs.
So you've got a lot of things
happening which shouldn't have
happened, lots of disasters.
But in my view that
says very little.
If you see that in the sweep of
history, in the last 10,000
years of history, this is
a period of 30 years in
developing countries between
1960 and 1990.
Governments expanded a lot.
They tried a bunch
of new programs.
Many of them failed.
There was lots of corruption.
But I think if you see the sweep
of history, we are just
at the beginning of a process
of trying to create a more
humane social policy.
We're nowhere near the point
where we would like to be.
And this is no accident.
We just started.
And in that sense, if you want
to take that perspective that
this is really the beginning
in terms of any historical
perspective, we are kind of at
a very early point, then I
think the main lesson that we
suggest here should seem more
plausible, which is that we
really don't know very much.
We've been shooting
in the dark.
We expanded too fast.
We didn't know what
we were doing.
And we're still very early
in the process.
And what we need to do is step
back and figure out what works
and how to make it work.
And if you had to take
one lesson away from
this class, it's that.
But there is a way to learn much
better about what works
and what doesn't.
We haven't used it.
And that's no accident
because we are just
getting started really.
I think once you remember that
lesson of history, I think
things look less depressing and
more promising than they
would look otherwise.
I'm going to stop there.
Thank you and good luck for the
final exam and for all the
things you're going to
be doing after this.
[APPLAUSE]